[Music]
welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with something new
in the water that's actually incredibly
old
so-called samurai swimming requires some
serious skill and effort and lucy kraft
has the story
they surged their bodies out of the
water like flying fish
trading water while remaining almost
motionless swimmers perform routines
showcasing their core strength and
control
kicking furiously beneath the surface
they seem to walk through water
just like at judo matches judges use red
and white flags and competitors bow
all part of a strange and obscure
martial discipline called nihong eho a
classical swimming art of the samurai
we're here in the western city of kobe
where hundreds of japan's top samurai
swimmers ages 10 to 93 have gathered for
their annual tournament when it comes to
aquatic competition there's nothing like
it
it's meant to strengthen yourself
mentally and physically so director
yamanei to become one with the water
uniting with water means legs do most of
the work of propelling the body leaving
arms free for fighting the flying fish
technique was devised to eyeball the
enemy and scope out water hazards and
honestly it looks kind of weird
weird or not uk native tony cundy said
it's the most useful martial art he's
ever tried it's called the bosui nomaki
which basically means to have forgotten
that you're in water someone from my
tradition who's really mastered it can
get in the water and act and move as
freely as they would
on land
dating back to the 17th century marshall
swimming was designed for a country
surrounded by ocean and crisscrossed by
rivers just like feudal warriors
swimmers stay buoyant even in 40 pounds
of armor
instead of weapons modern swimmers carry
parasols perform fan tricks
and draw calligraphy
odd it may be but adherents say samurai
swimming still offers practical
techniques for survival in natural water
environments
for cbs saturday morning lucy craft
tokyo when you do your lifeguard test
you have to be able to tread for a
certain amount of time i don't remember
what that is but that is really hard to
keep drinking i should do a samurai
lifeguard test yes they should you
should teach it at every elementary
school
okay that there's your lesson plan from
michelle
today i like the flying fish technique
that was really good yes